on les appelle les jardiniers de la nuit
ces hommes comme Angel moyoli font
pousser les champignons de Paris sous
terre aujourd'hui seulement trois
champignonnistes exercent dans les
Yvelines un métier en perdition dont a
hérité Angel moyoli bah je suis né dans
les champignons ma famille mon
grand-père était championniste mes
parents champigniste donc c'est vrai que
je suis né dans le champignon j'ai
toujours conu ça vos oncles aussi mes
oncles aussi toute la famille un savoir
transmis de génération en génération
qu'Angel moyoli souhaite partager avec
le public lors des journée du
patrimoine c'est le patrimoine de la
région parisienne champion de Paris
comme on dit champion de Paris pas être
fait ailleurs Paris c'est ici la région
ilî de France c'est le début du champion
c'est
ici